I can't believe we're almost four months
into the fan funded version of the
Reuben report to say this has been a
crazy couple months doesn't even begin
to explain it our team has always worked
hard but since we went independent
things are at an entirely new level this
show based on honest conversation
exploring big ideas and not pretending
to have all the answers is by far the
most rewarding thing that I've ever done
and it's all thanks to you so to the
nearly 3,000 of you who have joined us
on patreon and to all of you who made
and continue to make contributions on
PayPal my team and I humbly thank you
all once again while I knew that going
independent was going to be a big lift I
didn't fully realize how many things
were about to change we've now built a
business from the ground up we had our
own production company and owned all of
our equipment and our content there's no
longer a middleman between me and my
audience I answer to nobody except when
David and Amira outvote me which has
happened more than I'd like to admit the
real beauty of fan funding the Rubin
report though is that you guys have
given us the budget to do the show as we
see fit as I said the day we launched we
now don't have to enter partnerships we
don't want to enter we don't have to
make sales deals that don't fit with our
ethos and most importantly we don't have
to answer to anyone but you
many people organizations and
Institute's reached out to us after we
relaunched to partner with us one way or
another we put them on the back burner
though because we wanted to let the dust
settle and make sure that we only
collaborated with like-minded projects
one that really piqued our interest was
the YouTube channel learn liberty after
doing a little digging I quickly
realized that they were a great fit for
our commitment to free speech and big
ideas see for yourself
learn liberty is your resource for
exploring the ideas of a free society we
tackle big questions about what makes a
society free or prosperous and how we
can improve the world we live in we
don't have all the answers but we've got
a lot of ideas by working with
professors from a range of academic
disciplines and letting them share their
own opinions we help you explore new
ways of looking for solutions to the
world's problems I then did even more
digging and found
they've made using Star Wars to explain
freedom war and more the force is strong
with these people so here's exactly what
we'll be doing together once a month
we'll be collaborating to bring you an
interview with a classical liberal
usually a professor for an interview
series based around free speech learn
liberty is reaching into their extensive
network to send us the guests and I'm
conducting the interviews as I would any
other with open dialog and a skeptical
eye the really cool part of this is that
the list of guests comes not only from
all over the country but from various
disciplines be it math science economics
or something else altogether
we'll explore how free speech really is
the cornerstone of a functioning
democracy and we'll dive into the
current political climate on various
college campuses our first collaboration
with learn Liberty will hit on both of
these topics I'll be sitting down with
the Carmack waterhouse professor of
legal theory at the Georgetown
University Law Center Randy Barnett
professor Barnett teaches constitutional
law and contracts and has also been a
visiting professor at Penn northwestern
and Harvard Law School he's argued in
front of the Supreme Court and has
written several books on the
Constitution Liberty and the rule of law
you know old school stuff so much of
what we're bombarded with in the
mainstream is designed to distract and
confuse us I like to think that the
Rubin report has been an antidote to
some of that lunacy I'm looking forward
to working with learning Liberty to
introduce you to academics intellectuals
and other bright people so that together
we can make America smart again